Structures can be thought of as file cabinets.
The file cabinet has folders that contain information.
To refer to a folder in the cabinet, you would call it
by the word associated with it.
For example, if a file cabinet was called Data,
we type Data dot Name to refer to the folder in which we
were going to store some data.
Here we are storing the word Mike in Data.Name.
We can add as many folders to this file cabinet
as we want just by typing the name of the file cabinet,
Data, followed by the dot symbol, and then the word we
want to associate with the folder.
This word is referred to as the field.
The folders themselves can contain any array.
They can be an array of numbers or cells or even more structures.
Typing Data.Lego equals redLego stores a redLego into the folder called Lego.
Data.Apple equals pioneerMac adds another folder named Apple and stores
a pioneerMac inside it.
Just like other arrays, arrays and structures can have multiple elements.
Adding a second element is like adding an extra file cabinet.
We can do this by typing data parentheses 1 comma 2
dot name equals Colin.
When this is done, every folder that was defined for the first structure
is copied over to the second structure.
There will already be three folders in this file cabinet.
The folders for Apple and Lego will be empty until we define them.
If we add a new folder to either element of the structure,
it will be added to both.